Ah, richtig schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Frau Keuner. Ich bin Sushi Dendeki hier für Sie.
Und ich möchte gerne Ihnen einen Annamnetsgeschef rechnen.
Kurz zum Ablauf, würde ich nach Ihren Personen nicht an Daten erfahren. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Paul Mühe.
Paul Müller.
Nein, Mühe. M-I-H-E.
Mühe.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Mühe?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 6.08.1968.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, solle ich?
Ich wiege noch 71 Kilo.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Mühe?
Ja, ich habe immer solche Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Manchmal habe ich auch Schmerzen hier so unterhalb vom Hals,
hinter den Brustbeinen.
Das brennt dann so.
Manchmal habe ich auch so ein bisschen Sud bringen.
Das wird aber nicht besser, sondern schlechter eigentlich.
Jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich muss doch mal zum Arzt gehen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen,
da Sie zu uns gekommen sind.
Herr Mühe, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Angefangen hat das schon seit drei Monaten.
Das ist aber immer schlimmer geworden.
Am Anfang war das so, wenn ich so ganz trockene,
feste Nahrung gegessen habe.
Wenn ich ein relativ trockenes Brot gegessen habe
und nicht viel getrunken dazu habe,
dann hat das Rutsch nicht so richtig.
Jetzt ist es bei allem festen Essen,
dass es richtig weh tut.
Selbst beim Trinken tut das ein bisschen weh.
Können Sie für die Fülligkeit einen guten Hyronter für Schlucken?
Ich kann die wohl schlucken, aber auch da tut es inzwischen weh.
Wenn ich etwas flüssig ist,
was ich joghurt oder Milch trinke,
dann ist das vielleicht bei drei.
Aber wenn ich etwas festes esse,
dann tut es sich schon deutlich mehr weh.
Dann ist das mehr als die Hälfte,
es ist vielleicht sogar sechs.
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft oder vorübergehend?
Nein, die sind insbesondere beim Schlucken
und dann bleiben die noch ein Moment hinterher.
Sie haben auch Sotbrannen,
haben Sie auch aufstoßen?
Nein, aufstoßen eigentlich nicht so sehr.
Dass da irgendwas hochkommt,
muss manchmal so ein bisschen,
wenn ich Bier trinke, dann kommt ein bisschen Kohlendäure hoch.
Aber richtig doll aufstoßen muss ich nicht.
Haben Sie
Firmarte, Schleim im Mund?
Ja, ich habe das.
Morgen muss ich ziemlich viel Schleim abhusten.
Das merke ich.
Da habe ich Husten und da kommt auch mal irgendwas raus.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Der ist zurzeit nicht gut, wirklich.
Ich habe auch deutlich abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilo?
80 Kilo gewogen.
Ich habe mich dann länger nicht gewungen,
aber neulich habe ich mal gedacht, die Rosen schlackern so.
Gehen wir auf die Waage.
Dann habe ich festgestellt, dass ich nur noch 71 Kilo wiege.
Ich habe seit Rom abgenommen.
Vielleicht in einem halben Jahr oder so.
Ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft.
Ist denen über
Wenn ich so dolles Rot brenne,
ist mir vielleicht mal ein bisschen schlecht.
Aber auch wenn ich merke,
dass die Schmerzen beim Schlucken so doll sind,
dann habe ich ein bisschen Widerstand.
Dann mag ich auch nichts mehr essen.
Aber so richtig schlimme Übelkeit habe ich nicht.
Ich musste mich auch nicht übergeben.
Okay, gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, also
Durchschlafen tue ich nicht so sehr gut.
Zwischendurch muss ich mal auf die Toilette.
Oder ich wach auf,
weil das ein bisschen brennt im Hals.
Das passiert schon mal.
Wie viel mal gehen Sie zur Toilette beim Mosulessen?
In der Nacht?
Vielleicht noch so einmal zusätzlich.
Wenn ich dann aufwache,
dann gehe ich halt auf die Toilette.
Das ist nicht jede Nacht, aber hin und wieder mal.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Atmen?
Beim Atmen?
Nein, beim Atmen.
So habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Mosulessen und Sputulgang?
Nein, ich nicht.
Sie wissen, Sie sehen mehr als in der Nacht?
Mehr als früher,
würde ich nicht sagen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Haben Sie viel bei Schutteifrost?
Nein, also so richtig fiebrig krank,
fühle ich mich nicht.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen schlapp.
Ich habe für mich alle Wiste gefragt.
Über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden
möchten Sie noch etwas ins Függen?
Nein, wir fühlen nicht ein, was ich Ihnen noch sagen kann.
Ich habe halt diese Schmerzen beim Schlucken
und die werden nicht besser, sondern schlechter.
Das ist eigentlich mein Hauptproblem.
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht in der Nacht gefühlt.
Ich habe nicht meinen Hauptproblem.
Haben Sie deswegen schon mal beim Arzt?
Bei meinem Haus noch so war ich noch nicht.
Okay.
Oder haben Sie deswegen etwas Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe am Anfang mal,
weil ich dachte, das sind normale Halsschmerzen.
Da habe ich mal so Lustabletten benutzt,
aber das habe ich dann bald aufgegeben.
Ich möchte wissen,
über Ihre Gesundheitszustand,
sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Also drei Corona-Hempfungen habe ich.
Und ansonsten, was man früher so als Kind bekommen hat.
Okay.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Medikamente oder Lehmensmitteln?
Nein.
Ich bin nicht bekannt bei mir an allergischen.
Haben Sie für alle Krankenhöhepfungen,
wie Blutzuckerkrankheit oder Blutdruck?
Ich habe ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck.
Das habe man schon vor 15 Jahren festgestellt.
Dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Nettoprolol 95.
Das ist eine sehr große Liste.
Einen Morgen.
Und sonst noch was?
Und dann nehme ich noch aspirin 100 einmal täglich.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ne, operiert wurde ich noch nicht.
Ich habe allerdings Krampf addern
und da sagt mein Hausarzt immer,
die müsste mal mal operieren.
Ich trage dann lieber Kompressionsstrümpfe.
Aber ich hatte auch schon mal eine Thrombose.
Da hatte ich sogar auch eine Lungenembolie.
Da war ich ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus.
Aber ansonsten operiert worden bin ich wirklich noch nicht.
Okay.
Wann war das?
Die Thrombose und die Lungenembolie, das war vor vier Jahren.
Deswegen nehme ich auch das aspirin immer noch.
Okay.
Ich möchte wissen über Ihre Nubankilvern heute.
Rachen Sie?
Ja, ja, ich rauche schon.
Seit wann rachen Sie?
Also 30 Jahren.
Wie viele Kröte rachen Sie täglich?
Ja, so 1,5 Päckchen.
Ja, so 1,5 Päckchen am Tag rauche ich schon.
Ja.
Obben Sie schon mal versuchen,
mit dem Rachen aufzuhören?
Ja, versuchen hat das bestimmt jeder Raucher schon mal,
weil es zu furchtbar teuer ist.
Und jetzt in letzter Zeit schmecken die Zigaretten
auch gerade nicht so gut, muss ich sagen.
Wenn ich so Sud brennen habe,
dann schmecken die Zigaretten auch nicht so gut.
Aber trotzdem kann ich die Finger nicht davon lassen.
Ja, das rauchen schadete die Gesundheit.
Ich empfehle Ihnen mit dem Rachen.
Ja, da stehen Sie auch immer drauf auf den Packungen.
Ja, ich weiß das.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sie trinken Bier?
Ja, so 2, 3 Bier trinke ich am Tag.
Also 2, 3 Mal in der Woche gibt es auch noch Schnäppchen dazu.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
So wie jeder, seit 16 über 17.
Mit 16 Jahren?
Mit 16, ja, da hat man angefangen,
bei Bier zu trinken.
Sie solst ein bisschen leicht auf mit dem Alkohol,
so redet es zu höhlen.
Ja, das ist so.
Ja, aber wenn man noch schlafen kann,
dann hat man die Gesundheit.
Ja, aber gehört ja irgendwie auch dazu,
zu meinem Tageslauf.
Sie können vielleicht
so ruhig finden, andere Möglichkeiten,
bei uns sind es schon so mit Alkohol.
Ja.
So viel ist das ja nun auch nicht.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen, da habe ich noch nichts mit zu tun.
Okay.
Ich habe für mich alle Wichtige gefragt,
gestartet, möchten Sie noch was hinzufügen?
Ich wüsste Ihnen jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen könnte.
Ich hatte noch ein paar Fragen,
Krankheiten Ihrer Eltern,
wie hat Ihre Eltern gesund?
Nee, also die Krampfalern,
die habe ich von meiner Mutter geerbt.
Die hat auch ordentliche Krampfalern.
Und mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Aber Sie geschwester?
Ja, ich hatte einen Bruder,
der hatte aber Krebs in der Bauchspeiche drüge.
Der ist also nicht auch so gut.
Er ist schon gestorben.
Mein Bruder ist gestorben da dran, ja.
Ja, das tut mir leid.
Wann ist er gestorben?
Ja, das ist jetzt ein paar Jahre her.
Der war, der ist älter als ich.
Der war so 54.
Also so alt wie ich jetzt eigentlich, ja.
Okay.
Das tut mir leid.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Angestellter bei der Handwerkskammer.
Handwerkskammer.
Kammer.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieben.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, aber die sind schon groß.
Die sind aus dem Haus.
Machen Sie sportische Aktivitäten regelmäßig?
Regelmäßig, ja.
Hin und wieder fahre ich mit dem Fahrrad, wenn das Wetter gut ist.
Aber sonst mache ich eigentlich keinen Sport.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Alltag?
Ja, also nicht wirklich schlimm und stressnah.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ja, ich habe auch eine andere Arbeit.
Ich kann nicht sagen.
Ja, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch was hinzufügen?
Machen Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich meine, ich habe natürlich die Frage.
Was kann das sein und was kann man dagegen machen?
Gibt es irgendein Medikament,
dass ich nicht mehr diese Schluckschmerzen habe?
Und natürlich auch die Frage,
was steckt dahinter, ist das irgendwas, was gefährlich ist?
Ich war mutter.
Sie haben Probleme mit dem Speiser.
Die Diagnose festschüttert.
Brauche ich ein paar Untersuchungen.
Ich werde sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab und ein paar Bildgewendnisse.
Ich habe eine kleine Komponie.
Ich werden mir das Bild Ebenen und Farbe mit international und dem AutpRIST.
oder mit international und mit dem Autoph Uno exertieren.
Ja, das hat mich kardeşim und das Problem erst.
Ja, fit ist was dort gerade,
wo man grünen kann.
Ja, erst würde ich eine Magentship,
Magenshipikulierung würde ich durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls als Erweiterter Untersuchung würde ich eine Computer-Thomografie durchführen.
Und das hat eine Strahl belastung?
Die Magenshipikulierung hat keine Strahl belastung.
Das ist eine Untersuchung mithalf eines Geräts.
Die flexible und biegsame Schlaufe am Ende mit Kamera und Licht
wird durch den Mund bis Magen geschoben.
Kriegt man dann zu einer Kose?
Sie sollten vielleicht ein leicht berühmtes Mittel bekommen,
um die unangenehme, nicht zu früllen.
Wenn ich hauptsache, merke ich es nicht.
Ich werde Ihnen gleich kommen.
Können Sie bitte im Marsch warten?
Ja, dann warte ich auf Sie im Marsch.
Ich habe einen Kollegen an die Frage.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genaue Schreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen brennend?
Ja, ich würde sagen, die Schmerzen sind drückend und brennend.
Ich stamm die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus.
Sie sind nicht strahlend, sie sind ganz lokalisiert.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Haltem oder Gummioartigeschwellen im Hals haben?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit die Hautveränderungen aufgefallen?
Ich habe mich nicht so genau bemerkt, aber ich habe nichts aufgefallen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es Müdigkeit ist.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen schlapp.
Nein, es tut es nur bei Schluckwähen.
Ohne Nahrungsschuck, man hat ja klar Schluck, wenn man zwischendurch Speichel runter.
Normalerweise tut es nur bei Essen und Trinken.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es Müdigkeit ist.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, dass es Müdigkeit ist.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es Müdigkeit ist.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patientin, Herr Paul Mühe, vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, was haben Sie denn mit Herrn Mühe besprochen?
Herr Mühe ist 54 Jahre alt, 6., 8., 8. und 6. Geboren.
Er ist 1,78 m groß und 71 Kilometer alt.
Herr Mühe, ich habe seit drei Monaten mit Herrn Mühe mitgegeben.
Ich habe die Schmerz im Hals und Retrosyternalbeirat und eine Druckende brennende Retrosyternale.
Ich habe die Schmerz vorhin berichtet.
Vorher eine Pyrosis-Leide.
Ich habe die Schmerz-Intell-State bei Feste Ernehrung und Zechs,
bei Flüssige Ernehrung und bei drei Angegeben.
bei Flüssige Ernehrung und Zechs,
bei Flüssigen Ernehrung und Zechs,
in der Zeit.
Ich habe brennt,
für seit 50 Jahren bekannt, dagegen eine Methoprolor 590 Milligramm einmal morgens ein.
Und eine Varecoz ist bei ihm bekannt, deswegen nehme ich 100 Milligramm einmal morgens.
Er hat vor vier Jahren eine Lungenembolie mit tiefen Thrombose unterzogen.
Er wurde niemals operiert und er ist drauf mit 45 Pkms,
und er ist an Apoplex erleidert.
Apoplex ist ein Punktereignis.
Sein Bruder ist an Pankreas Karschnamen vor ein paar Jahren gestorben.
Er ist Handwerkskammer und er ist geschieden und habe zwei erwachsene Kinder.
Er macht als supportische Aktivitäten, ab und zu verratfahren.
Er hat keine Stress bei der Arbeit und im Alltag.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose aus dem Pferdkarschnamen,
als differenzialer Diagnostisch,
als Lungenkrebs, medialstil, Lymphoma, inbetracht.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose aus dem Pferdkarschnamen,
als auf der Abklärung,
als der Patientin ausführlich körperlich unterzogen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung ist das Lymphknoten ab,
in Heißbärer und supereklavillakal,
in Aksiller, in Gynalbärer.
Es ist ein Bauchab,
ob es irgendeinem Organe gibt.
Vielleicht, weil ich Magen bricht,
erwarte ich eine Doructolens im Epigastrialbera.
Er hat kein Appetit und viel Gewichtabnahme.
Er hat auch eine Verdachtdiagnose aus dem Pferdkarschnamen,
als der Pferdkarschnamen,
als der Lymphomus,
als die Lymphomus,
als Lymphomus die Pferdkarschuhe,
die Lymphomus,
einen Bau-Ultra-Schein durchführen, ob mögliche Magen, Karsinom oder andere Karsinom auszuschließen.
Im Diagnostik wurde ich eine Özöphogogastrodenoskopie durchführen.
Was müssen wir dann noch machen?
Ich würde eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen, eine solche Bischöpfung.
Wenn das positiv ist, wenn wir feststellen, da ist wirklich was Böses, was müssen wir dann noch machen?
Im schweren Fall kommt eine Özöphageastante in Prag.
Sie sind schon bei der Therapie. Ich bin noch bei der Diagnostik.
Ich würde auch eine Torax mit Abdomenthomografie durchführen.
Für eine Skeletz-Cintigraphie, dass man guckt, ob der Tumor irgendwo gestreut hat.
Die Therapie ist eine teure Diagnostik-Methode.
Deswegen ist das nicht eine routimästige Teilzierung.
Wir müssen jetzt über die Therapie.
Wenn es ganz schlimm ist, muss man da ins Den setzen.
Die Prognose von Özöphagiskalznorm ist die Infaust.
Deswegen hat es zu wenige Patienten eine Chance für Operationen.
Normalerweise kommt eine Palästrophie in Prag mit Chemotherapie, Radiotherapie, Schmerz-Therapie.
Ernehmungsschützen mit der Gastrostomie oder eine parentelle Nutrition.
Dass er eine Magen Sonne kriegt, damit er gar nicht den Özöphagus belasten muss.
Oder dass er eine Weide parenterale wird.
Das klingt auch vernünftig.
Dann wollen wir hoffen, dass der Patient das nicht hat, sondern dass er einen Negativen befunden hat.
Er könnte einen Reflux haben, aber es klingt nicht so gut.
Zumal er auch ordentlich Risikofaktoren bringt.
Das ist für die Situation.
Ich möchte die Berichte wissen, was bei den Untersuchungen rausgekommen ist.
Ich bin heute ein bisschen durcheinander entschuldigt.
Vielleicht Prüfungssythrys.
Ich fand die heute besser als die letzte noch.
Sprachlich war das ziemlich gut.
Sie haben nichts ausgelassen, sowohl beim Fragen.
Erst habe ich gedacht, sie hört schon auf zu fragen, aber dann kamen noch die weiteren Fragen.
Ich habe eine einzige Formulierung.
Da müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen.
Vor vier Jahren hatte er eine Trombose und eine Lungenembolie.
Daran hat er gelitten.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat sich unterzogen.
Unterziehen kann man sich nur einer Maßnahme.
Er hat sich eine Operation unterzogen.
Oder was weiß ich, eine Chemotherapie.
Er wurde einer Therapie unterzogen.
An einer Erkrankung kann man nur leiden.
Das ist sprachlich mir aufgefallen.
Ansonsten fand ich das sprachlich ziemlich flüssig.
Es gibt keine Missverständnis.
Ich fand jetzt kein Missverständnis.
Das war das einzige.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Er trinkt 2-3 Flaschen Bier am Tag.
Und zusätzlich noch Schnaps.
Und das schon seit er 16 ist.
Er trinkt 2-3 Flaschen Bier.
Und schnappt seit 16.
Er hatte angefangen, Alkohol zu trinken.
Er hat das auch gesagt.
Er hat sich eingependelt.
Er trinkt am Tag.
Er schnappt mehr in der Woche.
Das ist nicht gesund.
Das haben sie schon im Klag gemacht.